oh yeah they gathered under the banner
of safe Hong Kong to denounce recent
violence during protests and to show
support for the police here in Tamar
Park the allegiance to China is clear
but there's more than just that
the crowd is mostly middle-aged or older
part of a generation that grew under
British colonial rule and want to
protect their lifestyle David Chiu works
in the service industry he is one of 200
government supporters from the same
neighborhood I absolutely don't accept
the demands of the protesters it's not
what the general public wants none of
them demands can be met they are all
nonsense and excuses people here are
calling on the police to uphold law and
order and blame protesters for the
recent outbursts of violence and we all
love Hong Kong we all part of China will
firmly believe that so I don't want this
place to be ruined and so I came back
and support and do the rally I could not
take any violent demonstration that we
can see as witnessed by so many young
riders you know and that's devastating
he's killing my killing my feeling
across Hong Kong's harbor in Kowloon
David Sun March with the pro-democracy
protesters mostly young people who fear
what they perceive as the growing
influence of the Chinese government in
Hong Kong's affairs they feel their
demands are being ignored and
frustration is growing shame I said that
they've cubes we feel sane to respond to
our
wish myself Airy and we have a lot of
emotion in this society now so I think
that we come out is to master hope that
they can respond to our part of the
anger is also towards the police whom
they accuse of using excessive force but
the protesters are under pressure for
bringing chaos to the streets these
division threatened to take Hong Kong
apart between a generation content with
the present and one that is worried
about the future when Abdel Hamid
al-jazeera
Hong Kong